now this rhinoceros viper bears a
warning on its head for those who know
the species this giant arrow screams
contains lethal venom look out
Danger Danger I'm going to bite kill and
eat you
whereas this vine snake is more subtle
it has a super bright
dayglo tongue that contrasts with its
dull colored magnificently camouflaged
body come on could you tell the snake
from the tree branch if you weren't
looking for it it can play possum and
lay in wait for prey but when it itself
becomes prey that's where the tongue
comes in suddenly this green tree branch
sticks out it's bright orange tongue
that says mess with me yeah sure if you
want a great big tooth full of poison
thing is the vine snake is not venomous
but the Predators don't need to know
that nice tricking but here's the
trickiest snake of all the two-headed
snake you talk about crafty defense and
office
this is the tale of the two-headed snake
the tail looks more like the head than
the head the false head quote keeps
guard sitting on the coils while the
real head sneaks off looking for food
now here's the real head it has no
distinguishing features those are on the
tail this means that a predator is
likely to attack the tail instead of a
head thinking the tail is the head
instead of the head being the tail just
to complete the confusing illusion the
tail actually mimics the defensive
strikes made by the head of a retreating
snake so ends the tail of the snake with
a head like tail and a tail like